from what i heard you actually you had a
lesson with andrea where you learned the
ponziani opening right
yeah
do you remember much from that lesson
um i remember it relatively so so the
thing with the ponziani by the way is is
really funny i had a lesson with andrea
and they were like yeah ponziani is
really cool and then i played against a
few people
then i had a new lesson with nemo i
believe it was nemo and they were like
oh yeah don't
um ultimately it's up to you ponziani i
think it's a very effective opening
against players below like any rating
below 2000
but it takes some work to understand
like what you're supposed to do
right
so i i i would go i would go uh g3 with
the knight
uh i think you mean f3 f3 you also have
the ability to make moves
oh so yeah
yeah and then knight c6
uh and then that c3
so
the the whole point of ponziani you just
want to take over the center
and i think this is aligned with kind of
your understanding and opening you want
to get two pawns in the center have good
control have nice development
now when you play this opening there's a
few things you kind of have to be ready
for
is what happens when black
attacks your pawn
either knight f6 or d5
um
and i'll go through
um
so
first of all if black doesn't attack
your pawn like a lot of times black
might play a move like d6 or
bishop c5 these are like the
i'll call them the beginner moves
first of all bishop c5 it's an attempt
to prevent you from playing d4
it actually makes d4 stronger
because you attack the bishop
and your pawn is supported three times
and if black goes for the trade trade
if they try taking on d4 again you're
going to be winning material because
you'll have the last capture yeah
on top of that black's gonna have to
move the bishop again
if they play some check you just
complete developing and you have
really nice center
everything's offended
um i play this a lot like when i stream
chess and play against viewers or noobs
online
i'll get this position a decent amount
and players will walk into the trap
after d6 i'll play d5
they'll move their knights
and now white to move and win a piece
that right
very good yeah queen a4 the same tactic
as previously in the sicilian position
so
yeah this queen a4 move will come up a
lot also in ponziani
um
if they play d6
you just play d4 it's like if they don't
challenge you you play d4 yeah i'll show
you one trap from here which is kind of
a nice one
let's imagine they play knight f6
the move i really enjoy playing here
okay is pawn h3
which looks a bit strange but the point
is you're preventing the bishop from
developing actively
and if they want to develop to e6
you fork them
right so that's that's a simple trap
the more complicated trap is what
happens if they take your pawn yeah i
was going to say what if they just take
it
um
this is a question for you white to move
you can win material by force
even though you just lost a pawn you can
win one of the knights
um
and
be on the table oh you can just do that
good
yeah pawn d5 really nice move removing
this knight wow and setting up queen a4
yeah you open the fourth rank and the
diagonal
that's good
very common ponziani trap
uh this can also happen like if they
take first
and then take you still have the same
idea
and i can't tell you how many games i've
had this i even had this against nemo
like i played her in the splits match
she took the pawn i played d5 and then
she resigned after queen a4
i'll play a ponziani
ponziani time
fun opening
very effective opening against like
beginner players
but maybe it's it could be effective
against her
if she's not usually an e5 player
yeah d6 is it's playable
sometimes leads to a passive position
oh no my pawn
please take it please
if if knight takes i i push knight moves
and i fork the the king and knight
it's a classic trap
maybe she's thinking about it
wow it worked
yeah this is like um
kind of unique to the ponziani it's a
nice opening trap
i had this uh one year at us open
like the first round
now i think she's realizing yeah
so even strong players will walk into
this
that's cool
yeah
um that's one of the things i like with
ponziani there is
uh there's of course uh
approach where you're just trying to
control the center and be very solid but
there's also kind of these tricky traps
that can catch a lot of players off
guard
[Music]
um let's look at like the more
challenging moves
uh perhaps starting with d5
i did look up some of your games like
you've had this position and you know
the right moves yeah i it was it was
something to do with this
good yeah where you pressure
black from very early
i know you had one game where your
opponent played bishop d7
and
this just loses the pawn you take the
pawn
and you're okay with discoveries the
worst black can do to you is knight d4
hitting your queen
you just move back
if they take you take
now i know the one game i don't know how
recent it was but you played knight a3
in this position
i did
i believe so
okay it may have been a while ago like i
just kind of
what i did i downloaded all your games
and looked into uh this opening
um
what you would want to do is is focus on
your kingside development get your king
castled
and also defend this pawn
yeah it would be something like um
bishop to c4 bishop c4 great move yeah
and then you just want to play d3 castle
bishop g5
even if you end up losing back upon
uh then it's just equal material and
you'll have a fine position
um
what a lot of players will do is take on
e4 like they'll see the pin but they see
oh you can trade pawns
um
this is a move i encounter most online
and here
you keep your queen on a4 you win the e5
pawn
so creating this pin
um
and now you have a double attack you're
threatening to take on c6
but also to take on e4
so the only way black can defend
everything is to play queen d5
so defense this is actually very
multi-purpose move defending defending
attacking
you very simply take back on c6
and you're not quite winning material
here material here unless black takes
with a queen
then then your eyes should light up
because what does white do
oh uh bishop to b5 there should be five
bingo and you you win the queen so black
would have to take with a pawn
and then the problem for black is the
structure is really really weak
um c6 is weak e4 is weak
and i'm starting to like the ponziani
more now that's my goal is to to make
you like it to give you some confidence
uh to prove all the doubters wrong
yeah and you continue here with bishop
c4
black doesn't have time to develop the
minor pieces because the queen's hit
you're um
you're still pressuring the pawns the
queen has to stay defending this pawn
black might play a move like this then
you just castle
get your rook in
there's a concept in chess it's called
developing with tempo
or developing with attack
where you bring in
bring in pieces to the game while making
threats
so bishop c4 was developing with tempo
rookie one will
develop and it gives you time and it
slows down the opponent from completing
their own development
and a plan like this and this
box cannot be under major major pressure
right
so
um
[Music]
i know we're going through like a lot of
different lines but uh that was
basically
after d5 queen a4 i think you you'll
you know enough to
to look forward to going into that
if black doesn't play d5
the most common move is knight f6
which i've seen you you've had a lot of
games in
and you've never played the right move
in this position
no
okay i think you've usually like been
concerned about your pawn you've played
either
like d3 or queen c2
and just trying to like be solid
the rule in ponziani if black doesn't
play d5
you play d4
no matter what
the d5 is met with queen a4 everything
else is met with d4
so 96 you play d4
um
and you are allowing black to win a pawn
but you're going to win it straight back
so
the two main moves here for black are
either takes or takes
whatever black does
you're going to push a pawn forward
and attack one of the knights
yeah so let me test you if black takes
this pawn
what'd you do d5 yeah
and black takes this pawn
you push to e5 awesome
let's start with this line
okay because um i think it's most common
you'll push e5
i can't tell you how many times i've had
this position where black will go wrong
because there's only one good
night move for black
which a lot of players just don't play
um
i'll actually pose this to you as a
question like if you were black what
would you do with your knights
realistically i would literally put it
in e4 and just think about it that's one
of the the main mistakes here for black
the reason this is a mistake is because
after queen e2
the knights attacked again black would
really want to defend it with a pawn
let's say d5
but how can you
really punish black here upper shot yeah
okay you've you you know it i saw you on
passante yesterday the crowd was going
wild
here it's extra powerful
because not only do you remove the
defender of the knight
but you vacate the e-file so now the
knight is pinned to the king
on top of that you're controlling e7 so
black doesn't have queen e7
[Music]
right
and the knight is attacked and pinned if
bishop
to
f5 um
i'm actually trying to remember i think
just knight t2 and you're gonna win the
knight
black doesn't have another way to defend
right
so
after queen e2 black's already in
trouble if they play knight c5 you take
again you you keep your initiative you
keep making threats and
lights being kicked around to some
awkward swear if here you can fork
and uh
yeah you're actually not winning
material here because knight d4 but
um
you can trade and just you're fully
dominating the center with
a great position
so
that's very very cool
um yeah again one of the reasons why i
like ponziani is there's so many ways
for black to go wrong
if black plays like this move this move
or this move
you just take and you have really nice
center pawns very easy development
um
same thing with queen e7
which a lot of players will play
thinking they're so clever like they're
pinning your pawn they're attacking it
twice
but after you take
black is in a situation where now the
bishop is stuck behind the queen
and then the king can't easily castle
and the kings will be stuck in the
center for longer
if they try and play d6 attacking your
pinned pawn
you respond with a counter pin
and that way you reinforce e5 if there's
a trade you just take back
and
you're gonna have
a really nice position like black can't
win the pawn
uh maybe black could try with knight g4
but then you just castle
don't even attempt to defend the pawn
now in this position you can you can say
oh no my pawn
because black can win it
but if they win it uh how do you punish
them
oh this is rook e1 rookie one yeah it's
very common theme in ponziani where you
you castle sooner than your opponent you
get to the file
and the center is open like this there's
bound to be some problems for black
okay so i'm trying to be thorough here
but
like going back to this position
the only good move for black is knight
d5
so
saving
uh saving the knight putting it on a
good central square
and here i'll show you
show you like two more moves and then
you'll be good to go
okay
the first move i recommend is queen b3
not taking the pawn yet but just
improving this is another developing
with tempo move
you activate your queen
and you make a threat the only good
square for the knight is uh back to b6
and then you take on if on d4
and
this is really all you need to know at
least in this specific variation if you
get to this position
great center more space
easy development with your bishops
maybe one more tip if black ever
moves a d-pawn the best square for your
bishop is to b5 to pin the knight
i had a game once um against an 1800
rated player they played d5
i played bishop e5
they checked me
white to move
you could just take the [ __ ] yeah you
just take the bishop yeah you just take
it whatever nightly
my opponent resigned after this so
a nice little trap
so bishop b5 is nice because you pin the
knight but you prevent black from
developing actively
right yeah
so
um
yeah if you get this you're good to go
this is actually one of the main lines
in the panziani so
um
it's possible if you play the ponziano
correctly you could get this a decent
amount
let's go back actually actually seems
very cool all right now the other pawn
now the other pawn yeah so
if knight takes e4 e4
we push to d5 you push the d5 uh good
right the knight's attacked
most players will play knight e7
and now you just win back the pawn you
take on e5
yeah
and now i want to pose this as a
question let's imagine you're playing
black here what move would you play
hmm
[Music]
maybe either
d6 or
probably probably d6
yeah d6 is like the most natural
intuitive move like open up the bishop
attack the knights
d6 is a terrible terrible blunder
okay
so now let's let's flip a situation
white to move and punish this move
white's not going to be retrieved all
right all right okay okay i see it now i
see that you can win the knight with
what
okay so good it's good you remember
queen a4 you actually have a better move
here
queen a4 actually trades after
bishop d7 you win the night
then you lose back your knight yeah yeah
sure um
although maybe maybe 97 you're still
doing well
but there's a more powerful move um
[Music]
see this is scary right
maybe maybe hmm
i i'm not
against this because
i i feel like it's something to do with
with czech good you have the right idea
it's just about kind of
being confident with execution
right
um
to try and make things as simple as
possible you're checking the king
only way for black to get out of shack
is to block
you're controlling both these squares
more times
than black
so if black plays c6
oh actually first of all black plays
bishop d7 you take
okay and then you're gonna win the queen
yeah that's true if c6
you can take
and now you leave your knight undefended
but if takes
this is where things get really fun
like to move you have that you just take
and you're gonna be making a new queen
if bishop here
yeah your queen i would say uh
you could also take first um i would
take first because if if
oh i guess they can take with the oh no
they can't take with the king there's so
many ways to win this like takes on d7
or takes and making a new queen
everything works um
the reason why i like to take here is
because after takes it's immediately
mate
oh right right they can't take but if
you wanna like
there's so many ways to torture black
too like you could take and takes and
then you make a queen and then you have
two queens and
um black's already dead here
yeah
uh the best try for black is to take
back
with pawn
but then
you have time just to win material on c6
you take
you set up the discovery
[Music]
and if there's a trade
this is a uh
really nice tactic oh wow oh that's a
lot
too yeah and if here
you actually don't take the rook because
then black gets the bishop for it you
just take the knight
yeah if you take the rook you're only up
two points and then denies three yeah
i actually want to test you one move
further queenie seven
what would you play
um
i might just do queen eat
two queenie two completely fine
if you want it to be tricky castling is
a cool move where you
you say oh no my bishop but you win the
queen so oh yeah yeah you're right so i
think casting is a bit more useful
because you get out of the pin and you
set up
rookie one
so whenever the king and queen are
aligned like this and the files open
just try and get your rook to the e-file
as quickly as possible
yep
anyway um yeah someone is pointing out
in my chat i like the castling one that
was that was cool
yeah yeah there's like so many uh so
many of these ideas will come up in
in different types of positions but uh
even different types of openings
so yeah
um going back to actually going back
like to this key position we were just
looking at takes pawn push here you take
back
so it's a blunder for black to play d6
because of bishop e5
um
if black knows what they're doing
sorry i guess we have f6 there's f6
but this would
actually f6 is kind of interesting
um i'd really want to punish this move
like looking for queen h5 but then
there's g6 so
[Music]
uh
let me see if there's any way to punish
this move immediately
yeah with f6 you just move back
and this pawn is a bit out of place
and you just want to play bishop d3
teacher i want one too and then
in a better position
exactly like you're gonna have uh
[Music]
more
more potential to attack like you're
gonna castle sooner um
if knight g6
which is probably the best move for
black
again you just take
takes bishop d3 castling
very stable position
nothing much to worry about
really because now now
oh they do have the file
that's true but you're attacking the
knights
okay so the knight will probably move
back
um
yeah i remember this this is reminiscent
of what we looked at earlier
you're okay casting into this because
worst case scenario you just play h3 and
they can't really do much
and the prospect of rook e1 is much more
powerful
you're also also bishop f4 if you want
to um
be solid
um of course depending what black does
if black tries to win the pawn
then the knights left undefended all
lined with your queen
you actually have a nice kind of
tactical shot here bishop takes g6
yeah i was thinking that i was thinking
that it it looks good
and yeah then i mean black's really
underdeveloped rookie one's coming the
light's attacked
life is really good here
um
so i i tried to give you like the the
ponziani in a nutshell i know we went
kind of deep into lobby's lines um
you're more than welcome to like review
this uh this will all be saved in the
vaude too but
um i'd recommend like trying it out in
in practice
yeah i'm definitely gonna try uh the
ponziani a little bit more now
um cool rewatch the vod really just
don't do the wrong move in the ponziani
because i feel like
i have played the ponzioni before i feel
like i just don't necessarily make the
right move at the right time that's why
i wasn't too keen on it yet
yeah sometimes when learning a new
opening if you go wrong early then
you're just left in an unpleasant
situation
but if you know
if you know the right ideas and kind of
the right sequences then
it can be a lot more enjoyable to play
and
a lot of it is just putting in like the
practice like getting it in your games
if you run into something you didn't
weren't sure what to do or not so
comfortable with um
try to make note of it
uh if you have questions feel free to
just reach out but um be cool to like
see you playing this and
uh in games and just see how it goes